Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest is History and our second episode on oil, the history of oil, the way that it's shaped geopolitics over the past century and more with the brilliant Helen Thompson, Professor of Political Economy at the University of Cambridge. So in the last episode, Dominic was talking about oil as a curse. And that is quite a standard perspective that for lots of countries, the possession of oil has distorted their politics and has proven bad for the people who have that oil. Do you think that's true? Do you think the presence of oil in the country, that there is a kind of link often to the repressive regimes that tends to generate?
感谢收听《历史的 rest is history》。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目提前畅听以及我们备受喜爱的聊天社区会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的 rest is history》。这是我们关于石油的第二期节目——石油的历史，以及在过去一个多世纪里石油重塑地缘政治的方式。今天作客的嘉宾是剑桥大学政治经济学教授、才华横溢的海伦·汤普森。所以在上一期节目中，多米尼克谈到了石油是一种诅咒。这是一个相当标准的观点，即对于许多国家而言，拥有石油扭曲了他们的政治，并被证明对拥有石油的人民是有害的。你觉得这是真的吗？你认为一个国家存在石油，通常与它往往滋生的压迫性政权之间存在某种联系吗？
Well, I think the really interesting case here is the United States. Right on. The United States, you know, for a period of time, as I said, at the end of the 19th century and then again in the post Second World War period period probably actually in the 1930s as well uh it's the world's largest oil producer and as we know it's now again you know now and speaking this year 2022 it's back to being the world's largest oil producer it has been for a few years now um thanks to the shale boom and Cracking and all that. Yeah, obviously the American state and American politics doesn't really look like any Arab country's state and politics. It doesn't look like Cyrus Russia or the Soviet Union. It doesn't look like Mexico is full of that matter either.
嗯，我认为这里一个非常有趣的例子就是美国。没错。美国，你知道的，正如我所说，在一段时间里，在19世纪末，然后又在二战后的时期，可能实际上在20世纪30年代也是如此，它是世界上最大的石油生产国。正如我们所知，现在它又——（说到这里，今年是2022年）——重新成为了世界上最大的石油生产国，这几年一直如此，多亏了页岩油热潮、水力压裂法以及所有这些。是的，很明显，美国政府和美国政治看起来并不太像任何阿拉伯国家的政府和政治。它看起来不像是沙皇俄国或苏联。它看起来也不像墨西哥，或者诸如此类。
And yet I still think that there's more to the story of American democratic politics through the course of the 20th century than can be understood without seeing the impact that the United States oil production had. And I just give one example for that, which is the way in which Texas became such an important state. And so in 1930, the East Texan oil field was discovered by a wildcat, a driller. And at that point, it was the largest oil field that had ever been discovered anywhere in the world. And what we see from the through the 1930s is the rise of Texas's influence in American politics. You know, these big figures in Congress, culminating obviously in Lyndon Johnson, who Senate majority leader, and then went on to become president after Kennedy's assassination. And you might say as well,
然而我仍然认为，纵观整个20世纪，美国民主政治的故事还有更多的内涵，如果不看美国石油生产所产生的影响，就无法理解这些内涵。对此我只举一个例子，那就是德克萨斯州成为如此重要的一个州的过程。因此，在1930年，东德克萨斯油田被一名“野猫”钻探工发现了。在当时，这是世界上有史以来发现的最大的油田。我们从20世纪30年代看到的是，德州在美国政治中影响力的上升。你知道，国会里的这些大人物，其顶峰显然是林登·约翰逊，他曾任参议院多数党领袖，后来在肯尼迪遇刺后成为总统。你也可以说，
that the ways in which American politics shifted westward, as the New Deal era came to an end, bound up with that rise of Texas, if we pushed it a bit further than just the Johnson era. Even in a country like the United States, where the whole economy isn't running on oil, the whole of the state's finances isn't running on oil, it's still shaping the question of who has political influence in a country's politics. And even beyond that, Helen, I mean, oil, you know, in the 1950s, 1960s, 1970s, oil lobbyists played an enormous role in Washington. I mean, probably unrivaled by any other single lobby group. So you could argue that even getting apart from the demographic expansion of Texas or its obvious political role,
随着新政时代的结束，美国政治向西转型的种种方式，与德州的崛起息息相关——如果我们把时间推得比约翰逊时代稍远一点的话。即使在美国这样的国家，整个经济并非完全靠石油运转，整个国家的财政也并非完全靠石油运转，它依然在塑造着这样一个问题：谁在一个国家的政治中拥有政治影响力。不仅如此，海伦，我的意思是，石油——你知道的——在20世纪50年代、60年代、70年代，石油游说集团在华盛顿发挥了巨大的作用。我的意思是，可能没有任何其他单一的游说集团能与之匹敌。所以你可以争辩说，抛开德克萨斯州的人口扩张或其明显的政治角色不谈，
the oil money plays a massively distorting part in American politics. I mean, the interesting cases is, though, in 2016, just to skip on to that, is where you have the oil industry, the oil and gas industry, throwing huge amounts of money at a single candidate, Jeb Bush, to get the Republican nomination, the best financed presidential candidate there's ever been in terms of running for a nomination. And he doesn't get anywhere. I think, isn't it the highest he comes third in one of the primaries? He's low energy, ironically. That's what Trump called him. I very stupidly forgot to print off the questions, which is why I don't want to ask
石油资金在美国政治中扮演了极度扭曲的角色。我的意思是，不过有趣的一个例子发生在2016年，暂且跳到那个时候，当时石油工业、石油和天然气工业向单一候选人杰布·布什砸了巨量的资金，以助其获得共和党提名，这是竞选提名历史上资金最雄厚的总统候选人。然而他却一无所获。我想，他在初选中的最高排名是不是第三？讽刺的是，他活力不足（low energy）。这就是特朗普对他的称呼。我很愚蠢地忘记把问题打印出来了，这就是为什么我不想提问
the question. But I do remember, there was a question on twitter with which you engaged about dallas which was uh probably the most famous tv um soap opera in the world in the 70s and revolved around um a texas oil family um and the most notorious figure in that was jr ewing who was the kind of archetype of an American corporate baddie. Do you think that there's a... I mean, I don't want to oversimplify, but I'm going to. A sense that oil made the United States in its dealing with the broader world, a kind of geopolitical J.R. Ewing. I'm quite happy to talk about dallas i think that the the dallas is a really interesting phenomenon uh because you know the things that people you know those of us who watched it remember about it most are obviously the big things like you know like who shot jr um but
但我确实记得，推特上有一个你参与过讨论的问题，关于《达拉斯》，这可能是70年代世界上最著名的电视剧肥皂剧，围绕着一个德克萨斯石油家族展开，其中最臭名昭著的人物是J·R·尤因（J. R. Ewing），他是美国企业恶人的某种原型。你认为是否存在一种……我的意思是，我不想过度简化，但我还是会这么说：有一种感觉，即石油让美国在处理与更广阔世界的关系时，变成了一种地缘政治上的J·R·尤因？我很乐意谈谈《达拉斯》。我认为《达拉斯》真的是一个很有趣的现象，因为你知道，人们——我们这些看过它的人——对它记忆犹新的是那些显而易见的大事，比如“谁枪击了J·R”之类的，但
actually a lot of it you go back and look at a bit a lot of it is actually about oil they really are oil stories that are running through um most dallas um episodes and i think what's interesting is is that in some sense that jr represents what is necessary for the united states to do at the point of the end of the 1970s and interestingly you know his father jock eock Ewing, the patriarch of the family, he represents, I think, in the Dallas mythology, if you like, old American oil independence. So he's George W. Bush. He's a wildcat adriller in that East Texan oil field. And that's where he's made his money. And the thing about these guys is that they were just taking the chance. The big oil companies were not interested in the East Texas oil field
事实上，如果你回去重新审视一下，很多剧情其实都与石油有关。它们确实是贯穿《达拉斯》大部分剧集的石油故事。我认为有趣的是，在某种程度上，J·R代表了美国在20世纪70年代末所必须做的事情。有趣的是，你知道，他的父亲杰克·尤因（Jock Ewing），这个家族的大家长，我认为他在《达拉斯》的神话中，代表着老派的美国石油独立性。所以他就是小布什。他是东德克萨斯油田的一名野猫钻探工。他就是在那儿发家致富的。这些家伙的特点在于，他们只是在碰运气。大型石油公司一开始对东德克萨斯油田并不感兴趣
to begin with. They were just people, as the Depression had already taken hold, who were getting some land from one of the ranchers and trying their luck drilling on it. And that's what Jck ewing you know like represents but if you think when by the time the series starts as i recall is he's retired the company's been handed over to jr uh and he's very keen jr's always going on about how um the independence meaning not the big oil companies and there's a really crucial episode in which
。大萧条已经开始蔓延，他们只是一群从某个牧场主那里弄到一块土地，并试图在那里碰运气钻探的人。这就是杰克·尤因代表的东西。但如果你想想，当剧集开始时，据我回忆，他已经退休了，公司已经交给了J·R。而他非常热衷于此，J·R总是喋喋不休地谈论着“独立人士”——意思是不是指大型石油公司——并且有一个非常关键的剧集，其中
jr basically mortgages Southport. Which is their ranch. Which is the ranch, which has been in his mother's family for generations. Then he's done that in order to finance some wells in Southeast Asia. So, you know, America has to, J.R.'s turning abroad to try and find oil for Ewing Oil, which is in crisis because basically Cliff Barnes has got the – he's running something called the Office of Land Management in Texas. And he's basically closed down Ewing Oil, being able to produce in Texas. So JR's chasing off oil on the other side of the world. He thinks this is going to save the company.
J·R基本上抵押了南福克（Southfork）。也就是他们的牧场。也就是那个在他母亲家族传了几代的牧场。然后他这么做是为了资助东南亚的一些油井。所以，你知道的，美国必须——J·R正在向海外寻找石油，以拯救尤因石油公司（Ewing Oil），该公司正陷入危机，因为基本上克利夫·巴恩斯（Cliff Barnes）拿到了——他在德克萨斯州经营着一个叫土地管理局（Office of Land Management）的机构。他基本上剥夺了尤因石油公司在德克萨斯州开采的能力。所以J·R正在世界另一端追逐石油。他认为这能拯救公司。
Then flooding happens or something in the oil wells, and then the mortgage comes due on South Fork. And there's this moment, there's this great episode, it's the best Dallas episode, I think, in which basically Miss Ellie, who owns South Fork, it's her family's thing, has basically to allow drilling on South Fork in order to save Ewing Oil. And I think that this episode goes out in the aftermath of Jimmy Carter's Malay speech, where he's basically saying, look, we need to make sacrifices.
然后油井发生了水灾之类的事情，接着南福克的抵押贷款到期了。然后有这样一个时刻，这是一个绝妙的剧集——我认为是《达拉斯》最好的一集——基本上拥有南福克的埃莉小姐（Miss Ellie，这块地是她家族的），为了拯救尤因石油公司，不得不基本上允许在南福克进行钻探。我认为这一集播出时，正值吉米·卡特发表“萎靡不振演讲”（malaise speech）之后不久，他在演讲中基本上是在说：听着，我们需要做出牺牲。
We need to consume less. But actually what's going on in Dallas in this episode is basically saying, no, well, we have to make sacrifices, but we have to give something up that's sacred because we need to produce more oil and in a way it's all framed as kind of like Miss Ellie making this noble sacrifice because Ewing Oil must survive but actually really in some sense what's saving the day is is that JR is financing um Cliff Barnes running for office so that he will leave the Office of Land Management and Ewing Oil will no longer be controlled or constrained. So I think that JR is kind of like doing the unpalatable things all the time that are necessary for America in the symbolism Ewing Oil
我们需要减少消费。但实际上《达拉斯》这一集里发生的事情基本上是在说：不，好吧，我们必须做出牺牲，但我们必须放弃一些神圣的东西，因为我们需要生产更多的石油。在某种程度上，这一切都被包装成了一种埃莉小姐做出的崇高牺牲，因为尤因石油公司必须生存下去；但实际上，在某种程度上，真正解围的是J·R资助克利夫·巴恩斯竞选公职，这样他就会离开土地管理局，尤因石油公司将不再受到控制或束缚。所以我认为J·R一直在做那些令人不快的事情，而这些事情对于美国——在尤因石油公司的象征意义中——在这样一个美国不再是世界最大产油国的世界里生存下去，是必不可少的。
to survive in this world in which America is not the world's largest oil producing country. Because America loses its kind of oil self-sufficiency, doesn't it, in the 70s. And that's the context for Carter's Malay speech in 79. Absolutely, yeah. And that is the context. I mean, Dallas starts, I think, in like 1978. It's either 77 or 78. It's starting as all these, you know know there's an energy crisis going on in the
因为美国在70年代失去了某种石油自给自足能力，对吧？这就是卡特1979年发表萎靡不振演讲的背景。完全正确，是的。这就是背景。我的意思是，《达拉斯》开播于1978年左右，我记得是。要么是77年，要么是78年。它开播的时候，正是美国发生能源危机的时候
um united states um it's providing i think some commentary um on that um problem and and i say jockewing you know the patriarch of the family who who's done it in the old american way that's gone that doesn't work any longer in In some sense, JR is now necessary. And then if we fast forward back, well, actually, if we rewind back to what we were talking about a second ago, which was about the Gulf Wars. Now, I would imagine that there's a proportion of our listeners who will say sort of automatically, well,
，我认为它对那个问题提供了一些评论。而且我说过，杰克·尤因——这个家族的大家长——他是用老式美国方式做到这一点的，那种方式已经一去不复返了，在现在已经不管用了。在某种程度上，J·R现在是必不可少的。然后如果我们快进回来——好吧，实际上，如果我们倒回刚才讨论的事情，也就是关于海湾战争。现在，我想象我们的听众中有一部分人会自动说，
those wars were both really about oil. So 91, the liberation of Kuwait, and then 2003, George W. what's at stake is American and Western oil interests, that it would be a disaster for Saddam Hussein to control the oil fields in Kuwait. I think the second one is obviously a lot more, is a lot more difficult. I think there was a view at the time that was articulated, particularly, obviously, well, actually, not just on the left, which said that George Bush Jr. administration was pursuing this war for the interests of the oil companies, and, you know, stressed the relationship of Dick Cheney, his vice president, to the oil business. I don't think that that's right. I think, though, that we do need to see that there is an oil
这两场战争实际上都是为了石油。所以91年是解放科威特，然后2003年乔治·W·……其中利害攸关的是美国和西方的石油利益，如果萨达姆·侯赛因控制了科威特的油田，那将是一场灾难。我认为第二场战争显然要复杂得多，复杂得多。我认为当时有一种观点被表达出来，特别是——显然，不仅仅是在左翼——这种观点认为小布什政府发动这场战争是为了石油公司的利益，并且强调了他的副总统迪克·切尼与石油业务的关系。我不认为那是对的。不过，我认为我们确实需要看到这场战争背后存在着一个石油背景，它是否提供了比其他事情更具决定性的动机？我不知道，我也并不特别确定这有多重要。但我认为我们可以看到，布什政府上台时，有一种感觉，即美国面临着一个不断恶化的麻烦。一方面，我认为它觉得麻烦越来越大，是因为它能看出，随着中国经济的发展，中国将需要消耗比20世纪90年代多得多的石油。中国从1993年起就已经不再实现石油自给自足了。并且，到20世纪2000年代，世界上一些最大的油田也正在老化。当布什政府上台时，有三个重要的产油国因为这样那样的原因正处于制裁之下：伊朗、伊拉克和利比亚。
context to the war, whether it provides decisive motivations over other things. I don't know, and I'm not particularly sure it's that important. But I think that what we can see is that the Bush administration, when it comes in, has a sense that America's got a growing problem. It partly, I think, thinks it's got a growing problem because it can see that as China develops economically, that China's going to want to use a lot more oil than it was doing in the 1990s. And China had stopped being self-sufficient in oil from 1993. And there's also a sense in which some of the world's largest oil fields are aging by the 2000s. And when the Bush administration comes in, there are three significant oil producers that are under sanctions for one reason or another, Iran, Iraq and Libya.
而且可以肯定的是，尤其是迪克·切尼，有一种感觉认为那是站不住脚的，他们不能继续对这三个国家实施制裁并限制产量。所以我认为第二次海湾战争显然有一个石油方面的理性基础，也就是说，如果我们能在巴格达扶植一个不同的政府——如果我们能扶植一个对西方利益友好的政府——那么我们就能够解除对伊拉克的制裁，我们就能够鼓励伊拉克增加产量，包括允许西方石油公司获得投资机会。显然，那一部分实际上并没有成功。但我完全准备好承认，石油是第二次伊拉克战争中一个非常严肃的考量因素。
And it's certainly the case that Dick Cheney in particular had a sense that that was untenable, that they couldn't carry on with having sanctions on all three of these countries and restricting production. So I think that there's clearly an oil rationale for the second Gulf War, which is to say, if we can get a different gulf war which is to say if we can get a different government in place in baghdad if we can get one that's friendly to western um interests um then we'll be able to remove the sanctions off iraq um and we'll be able to encourage more production in iraq including allowing investment opportunities for the Western oil companies. Obviously, that part of it doesn't doesn't actually work out. But I'm quite prepared to say that oil is a very serious consideration in the second Iraq war.
但这不仅仅关乎石油。如果我们回到第一次海湾战争及其后续影响，以及它涉及这些禁飞行动、涉及在海湾地区进行军事巡逻以阻止伊拉克石油因制裁体制而流出，我认为可以公平地说，通过这种方式遏制伊拉克的军事行动实际上已经变得相当困难，而且在布什政府上台时，法国人已经退出了。因此，军事上的现状，我认为已经精疲力竭，或者至少变得越来越困难。
But it's not just about oil. If we go back to the first Gulf War and its aftermath and the fact that it involves these no-fly operations, it involves militarily policing the Gulf to stop Iraqi oil getting out because of the sanctioned regime, I think it's fair to say that actually the military side of containing Iraq that way had become quite difficult and the French had pulled out of it by the time that the Bush administration came into office. So the status quo militarily, I think, had reached its exhausted itself or is at least becoming more more difficult.
因此，无论是从石油角度还是从军事角度来看，人们都在寻求一种替代方案。所以，海伦，我们讨论了石油在美国内政中滋生的虚伪倾向。我们现在能不能把目光转向欧洲？我的意思是，对于缺乏本土石油的大型欧洲国家而言，争取能源独立的失败尝试构成了欧洲主导的欧亚大陆终结的一个或许具有决定性意义的部分。所以这意味着什么呢？我想，首先，在近代，实际上欧洲一直依赖美国维持石油流动的努力，尽管欧洲人可能出于道德原因反对它。他们在经济上仍然受益于它。欧洲发生的另一件事，远比美国更甚，那就是对替代能源的追求。在政策层面上，对全球变暖的焦虑在欧洲似乎比在美国感受得强烈得多。
And so an alternative was being sought, I think, on that side as well as on the oil side. So, Helen, we talked about the strain of hypocrisy that oil has fostered in American policy. Could we look now at Europe, which, I mean, you say, for the large European states bereft of domestic oil, the failed bids for energy independence constituted a perhaps decisive part of how European-dominated Eurasia came to an end. So what that meant was, I suppose, first of all, that in recent times, actually, Europe has been dependent on America's attempts to keep the oil flowing, even though Europeans may kind of object to it on moral grounds. They still benefit from it in economic grounds. The other thing that's happened in Europe, far more than in America, is a pursuit of alternative energy sources. And the anxiety about global warming, in policy terms, seems to have been felt much more strongly in Europe than in America. sink oil wells into South Fork to frack, to kind of develop national parks and smash it up to get oil out is an option in a way that it isn't in Europe. Do you think that would be fair? So the lack of oil in Europe has made hypocrites of us as well.
在南福克钻探石油、进行水力压裂、开发国家公园并将其砸个稀巴烂以开采石油，这在美国是一种选项，但在欧洲则不然。你觉得这公平吗？所以欧洲缺乏石油也让我们变得虚伪。
Yeah, I do think that. I think there was an understanding, actually, particularly in Germany earlier than elsewhere in Europe, that oil was going to run into difficulties of the kinds in which we've seen, perhaps we're beginning to see pretty clearly at the moment, and that there were issues with not only foreign dependency and not only the environmental consequences of the production of oil, but the straightforward future supply of oil. So the same kind of things that were concerning the Bush administration in the early 2000s about the future supply of oil, I think were concerning the German government in the 1990s. And Gerhard Schröder.
是的，我确实这么认为。我认为，实际上，特别是在德国，比欧洲其他地方更早有一种认识，即石油将陷入我们已经看到的这种困境——也许我们现在开始相当清楚地看到这种困境——不仅存在外国依赖的问题，不仅存在石油生产带来的环境后果的问题，还存在直截了当的未来石油供应问题。因此，20世纪2000年代初困扰布什政府的关于未来石油供应的同类问题，我认为在20世纪90年代也同样困扰着德国政府。还有格哈德·施罗德。
Yeah, in the 1990s. Yeah, so this is a whole other dimension, right, which is that Germany, obviously, I mean, this is incredibly controversial. Well, actually, we'll get on to Germany in a second. Let's put the Nord Stream pipelines on a shelf and dust them down to the delight of our German listeners. So the push for sustainability and for alternative sources of energy, Helen, I mean, do you see that going anywhere ultimately in Europe? Yes and no.
是的，在90年代。是的，所以这是完全不同的另一个维度，对吧？也就是说，德国，显然——我的意思是，这极其充满争议。好吧，事实上，我们一会儿就会谈到德国。让我们把北溪天然气管道放在一边，掸掉上面的灰尘，好让我们的德国听众大饱眼福。那么，海伦，对于可持续发展和替代能源的推动，你认为最终在欧洲会有什么结果吗？既是也不是。
I mean, clearly one of the reasons why European countries energy helen i mean do you see that going anywhere ultimately in europe yes and no i mean clearly one of the reasons why european countries have been so concerned about alternative energy is because fossil fuel energy after the age of coal has been so problematic for them actually in italy's case the age of coal was problematic because they didn't have any yeah so i think that partly is you've talked about this enough times in your podcast, human motivation is pretty complicated about any number of things. And I think that part of the reason why Europeans have always taken
我的意思是，显然欧洲国家能源——海伦，我是说，你认为最终在欧洲会有什么出路吗？既是也不是。我的意思是，很明显，欧洲国家之所以如此关注替代能源，原因之一是因为化石燃料能源在煤炭时代之后对他们来说一直是个大问题。事实上，就意大利而言，煤炭时代之所以成问题，是因为他们根本没有煤炭。是的，所以我想部分原因正如你在播客中多次谈到的那样，人类的动机对于任何数量的事情来说都是相当复杂的。并且我认为欧洲人之所以一直将——或者说很长一段时间以来一直将——
alternative, or for a long time now, have taken alternative energy more seriously, often the case in the United States, is because they have understood the geopolitical problems that are caused for Europe in a time in which oil and gas are the most important energy sources. So, of course, you would like leaving the climate motives aside. Of course, you would be hoping that there was a future in which alternative energies would do the same thing. And Europe will be in a much less disadvantageous position than it's been during the time of oil and gas. And I think, go back to Tom's point, is that there's been a certain inclination, I think, amongst many of us in Europe
替代能源看得更重（这通常是相对于美国而言的），部分原因在于他们已经理解了在石油和天然气是最重要能源的时代里，给欧洲带来的地缘政治问题。所以，当然，抛开气候动机不谈，你当然会希望未来有一种前景，让替代能源能够起到同样的作用。而欧洲的处境将不再像石油和天然气时代那样处于极度不利的地位。我认为，回到汤姆的观点，在欧洲的我们许多人当中，一直存在着一种特定的倾向，
to be morally disapproving of the way in which Americans produce oil, talk about it, etc., whilst at the same time benefiting from it. I don't think that many people, whatever actually in Europe or indeed anywhere else for that matter, whatever they might morally object to in fracking and shale oil actually would have liked to have lived in the world of the 2010s. Economically, if the shale oil boom hadn't taken place because we would then be living in already be living in an era of you know permanently high um oil prices that would have made economic growth very difficult and i think that there's a quite strong inclination to turn away from those um realities because they're not very they're not very palatable um yeah to look at that's all mentioned gerhard schroeder i i won't
即在道德上对美国人生产、谈论石油等方式持不赞成态度，同时又从中受益。我不认为有很多人——无论在欧洲还是世界上任何其他地方——无论他们对水力压裂法和页岩油在道德上有何反对，会愿意生活在2010年代的世界里。如果在经济上页岩油热潮没有发生，因为那样我们将生活在——已经生活在一个——你知道的，长期高油价的时代，那将使经济增长变得非常困难。我认为有一种相当强烈的倾向去回避这些现实，因为它们不是非常……它们不是非常合乎口味……是的，去审视。刚才提到了格哈德·施罗德，我不会
say gerhard schroeder is a friend of the show he's absolutely not uh and we were first shyster yeah i think we well he's out he was audi man wasn't he because of his number of marriages and then he became olympic man um because of the number of ring lord of the rings they call him in germany but also now he's obviously a sort of the poster boy for what what's perceived as Western appeasement, Western hypocrisy and sort of willful blindness towards Vladimir Putin's Russia. Now, how much do you think, Helen, that our European anxiety about energy, about dependence upon oil, distorted our dealings with Russia since, let's say, the war in Georgia or the occupation of Crimea? First of all, I think there is, to be fair to the European Union
说格哈德·施罗德是节目的朋友，他绝对不是。我们以前管他叫骗子，对吧？我想我们——他是“奥迪人”（Audi man），不是吗？因为他结过很多次婚，然后他变成了“指环王”（Lord of the Rings），因为他在德国被称为“指环王”——因为戒指的数量。但现在他显然也成了西方绥靖主义、西方伪善以及对弗拉基米尔·普京的俄罗斯表现出刻意盲目的某种海报男孩。海伦，你认为我们欧洲对能源的焦虑、对石油依赖的焦虑，在多大程度上扭曲了我们自——比如说——格鲁吉亚战争或克里米亚占领以来与俄罗斯的交往？首先，我认为，为了对欧盟
and to be fair to Britain, actually, as well, because for part of this story, it was a member of the European Union. I think you can see, going back to around 2000, where Putin's scarcely been in power, obviously, at that point, a concern about Europe's Russian gas dependency in particular, which is obviously more sort of entrenched, because at that point, pretty much all gas was coming through pipelines.
和英国保持公正——因为在这个故事的一部分中，英国曾是欧盟成员国——我认为你可以看到，追溯到2000年前后，当时普京几乎还没掌权，显然在那个时候，人们就已经对欧洲依赖俄罗斯天然气（尤其是俄罗斯天然气）产生了担忧，这种依赖显然更加根深蒂固，因为在那个时候，几乎所有的天然气都是通过管道输送的。
And it's going through Ukraine, right? The Russian gas is going through Ukraine. Yeah, going through Ukraine. And so I think that particularly actually the European Commission at times spent quite a lot of time trying to find alternatives. And the problem is that if you say, well, what were the alternatives for european external gas imports so i not the stuff that was coming not the gas that was already coming in produced in europe in the north sea you were talking really about azerbaijan and iran um
而且它是通过乌克兰输送的，对吧？俄罗斯天然气正通过乌克兰输送。是的，通过乌克兰输送。所以我认为，特别是欧盟委员会有时花了很多时间试图寻找替代方案。问题在于，如果你问：欧洲外部天然气进口的替代方案是什么——也就是说，不是那些在欧洲本土（北海）生产并输送过来的天然气——你实际上是在谈论阿塞拜疆和伊朗。
obviously iran's its own kind of problem where morality uh for its regime is concerned and the azerbaijani um or the oil from sorry the gas from azerbaijan complicated pipeline that got what got to be constructed for that and there's lots of politics around the gas in um azerbaijan so i don't think that in general there was an indifference to this question there was just a difficulty actually implementing alternatives i haven't said that i think the german situation with schroeder is a bit different because this wasn't just a question of like buying russian gas it was a question of like which pipelines russian gas was coming through and until that point in late 2005 where his government in its final weeks in office made the decision um to agree the first nordstream pipeline um with
显然伊朗有其自身关于政权道德问题的麻烦，而阿塞拜疆的——或者说来自阿塞拜疆的石油——抱歉，天然气——需要为此建设复杂的管道，并且围绕阿塞拜疆的天然气存在着大量的政治博弈。所以我认为，总体而言，并不是对这个问题漠不关心，而是在实施替代方案时确实存在困难。话虽如此，我认为德国在施罗德领导下的情况有些不同，因为这不仅仅是购买俄罗斯天然气的问题，而是俄罗斯天然气通过哪条管道输送的问题。直到2005年底那个时候，他的政府在其任期的最后几周做出决定，
russia that gas those guys gas pipelines were coming through um. So when Trudeau did that, I don't think he was actually blind to what the strategic ramifications of that were in terms of putting a pipeline under the Baltic Sea. That would, in time, from Putin's point of view, be a first move to cutting Ukraine out completely of the export of gas into northern um europe he was just indifferent and partly he was indifferent um because he was very soon after he left office going to material to benefit yeah um am i right that the the polish government compared it to the the nazi soviet yeah the then um polish foreign minister said it compared it to the the nazi so Yeah, the then Polish Foreign Minister compared it to the Nazi Soviet pact because obviously part of the Nazi Soviet pact was carving up Western Ukraine and handing it over to the Soviet Union in 1939.
同意与俄罗斯建设第一条北溪天然气管道，那些天然气管道才开始通过……所以当施罗德那样做时，我不认为他真的对这在波罗的海底下铺设一条管道的战略后果一无所知。从普京的角度来看，这在未来将是把乌克兰彻底排除在向北欧出口天然气之外的第一步。他只是漠不关心，部分原因是他卸任后不久就能获得切实的利益，是的。我没记错的话，当时的波兰政府曾将其比作纳粹苏联——是的，当时的波兰外交部长曾将其比作纳粹苏联。是的，当时的波兰外交部长曾将其比作纳粹苏联密约，因为显然纳粹苏联密约的一部分就是在1939年瓜分西乌克兰并将其移交给苏联。
Okay, we'll take a quick break there. Go and refill your tanks if you can afford it and we will see you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
好了，我们在这里稍作休息。如果你们负担得起的话，去把你们的油箱加满吧，我们一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的 rest is history》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestistertainment.com. That's TheRestIsEntertainment.com. Hello and welcome back to The Rest Is History. Helen, one of the really striking things about reading your book, and especially in the current context, is just how important Ukraine is. I mean, you keep talking about Ukraine, and obviously, you wrote this, it's well before Putin invaded Ukraine. But in terms of oil politics, what is the role of Ukraine? Okay, well, where oil is concerned is the pipeline actually goes back to the aftermath of Suez. When the West European governments are turning to Soviet oil. I should say the Italians have already been interested in it before the Suez crisis. Obviously, for that oil actually to be transported into Europe,
我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的优先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。这就是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的 rest is history》。海伦，读你的书时，最让人印象深刻的事情之一，特别是在当前的背景下，就是乌克兰究竟有多重要。我的意思是，你一直谈论乌克兰，很显然，你写这本书的时候，远在普京入侵乌克兰之前。但就石油政治而言，乌克兰的角色是什么？好的，好吧，就石油而言，这个管道其实可以追溯到苏伊士运河危机之后。当时西欧政府转向苏联石油。我应该说，意大利人在苏伊士运河危机之前就已经对它感兴趣了。显然，为了将这些石油真正运入欧洲，
it's got to come either by sea or it's got to come by pipeline. There's options with oil, which they weren't then later with later with um gas immediately anyway what happens in the early 60s is this pipeline that's called um one of its names anyway it has multiple names it's called the friendship pipeline which says something in its name when this is the you know the height of the cold war or one part of the cold war anyway not too far off the cuban missile crisis time um this pipeline is built. And the Kennedy administration is very, very unhappy about the building of this friendship pipeline and wants sanctions against the companies that are involved in building it
它必须通过海运，或者必须通过管道运输。石油是有多种选择的，而后来天然气则没有这种即时性。无论如何，在20世纪60年代初发生的事情是，这条被称为——它有多个名字，其中一个名字叫做“友谊管道”（Friendship Pipeline），这个名字在当时——这是冷战的高潮，或者是冷战的一部分，总之距离古巴导弹危机的时间不太远——这条管道建成了。
and a ban on the export of certain materials that are necessary in order to build it. But the West Europeans are pretty adamant about it and that they stand their ground against the Americans. And this is the first of the battles that take place. There's going to be replicated, you know, in the last 10 years or so over the Nord Stream pipeline. This is the first of the battles over the pipelines between European countries and the United States, where the United States wants to say, we don't want you to be doing this. But this pipeline, when it is built, it starts operating, I think, in 1964, and it goes through Ukraine and Belarus. And it is still the principal pipeline by which oil comes from Russia into Europe. The gas pipelines are different. The
肯尼迪政府对这条友谊管道的建设非常非常不满，并希望对参与建设的公司实施制裁，并禁止出口建设所需的某些材料。但西欧人非常坚定，他们在美国人面前坚守立场。这是爆发的第一场争端。在过去的十年左右里，这场争端将在北溪管道问题上再次上演。这是欧洲国家与美国之间关于管道的第一场争端，美国人当时想要说：我们不希望你们这样做。但这条管道建成后，开始投入运营——我想是在1964年——它穿过了乌克兰和白俄罗斯。它至今仍然是俄罗斯石油输往欧洲的主要管道。天然气管道则不同。
gas pipelines are built later. And it's the gas pipelines that Putin has been most interested in making redundant by not only putting pipelines that go under the Baltic Sea, so Nord Stream 1 and then the Nord Stream 2 one that was built but never looks like it's never now going to be used but also pipelines that go into the Black Sea to take gas into into southern Europe and about a year after the the Crimea crisis it was 2015 I think this right when Putin had his agreement to build a pipeline that goes under the Black Sea called TurkStream, the first TurkStream pipeline. He basically had Gazprom write to the European Commission and saying, once this is finished, once TurkStream is finished, no gas whatsoever will be coming into Europe via Ukraine. You will have to use these the the sea routes and do you think now so you said
天然气管道是后来修建的。普京最感兴趣的正是天然气管道，他想通过不仅铺设穿过波罗的海底部的管道（即北溪1号，以及建好但看起来永远不会再被使用的北溪2号），而且还铺设通往黑海以将天然气输往南欧的管道，来使天然气管道变得多余。在克里米亚危机大约一年后，我想是2015年，当时普京达成了修建一条穿过黑海的管道的协议，被称为“土耳其溪”（TurkStream）第一条土耳其溪管道。他基本上让俄罗斯天然气工业股份公司（Gazprom）致信欧盟委员会，称一旦这个项目完成，一旦土耳其溪完成，将再也没有任何天然气通过乌克兰流入欧洲。你们将不得不使用这些海上路线。你现在怎么看——所以你刚才谈到了
about um nordstrom 2 being nordstrom 2 has been cancelled you know people lost their jobs it appears to be definitively over and that's an extraordinary change given that what a year ago um all the sort of prognostications were about a future sort of you know russia and germany becoming ever more entangled in that kind of foreign policy because of them their sort of, you know, Russia and Germany becoming ever more entangled in that kind of foreign policy because of their sort of mutual dependence. I mean, do you think that what's happened in the last few weeks, therefore represents a seismic moment in terms of Germany's sense of its energy security, Europe's sense of its energy security? Or do you, I mean, I know we're not soothsayers, and we don't have crystal balls, so we don't know how it's going to play out. But is it possible that that Russo-German relationship could be revived in five or 10 years?
北溪2号被取消的事，北溪2号已经被取消了，人们失去了工作，它似乎已经彻底结束了。考虑到就在一年前，所有的预测都还在谈论未来俄罗斯和德国由于某种相互依赖，在那种外交政策上变得越发紧密……鉴于此，这是一个非同寻常的变化。我的意思是，你认为过去几周发生的事情，因此代表了德国对自身能源安全的感知、欧洲对自身能源安全的感知上的一个震撼性时刻吗？还是说——我知道我们不是预言家，我们也没有水晶球，所以我们不知道事情会如何发展——但这种俄德关系在五年或十年内有没有可能复苏？
I think there's two things at the moment that are pulling in the exact opposite direction. The first of them is that 50 years of not just German energy policy, but German foreign policy is shattered in the last few weeks. Because it wasn't just that Germany embraced the pipelines and the gas pipelines in particular, but I think it's fair to say that in the 70s, that that energy relationship with Russia was the material foundation of Ostpolitik, of West Germany's then turn to an accommodation with Russia, so with the Soviet Union, in the hope that in the end that would create a context in which the reunification of Germany one day could take place. And that energy relationship then survived into the post-Cold War world. And I think you
我认为目前有两股力量在向完全相反的方向拉扯。第一股力量是，过去几周里，不仅是德国的能源政策，而且是德国长达50年的外交政策，都被粉碎了。因为不仅仅是德国拥抱了管道，特别是天然气管道，而且我认为可以公平地说，在70年代，与俄罗斯的这种能源关系是“东方政策”（Ostpolitik）的物质基础，是西德当时转向与俄罗斯（即苏联）妥协的物质基础，其希望最终能创造一个环境，让德国有朝一日能够实现重新统一。这种能源关系随后在冷战后的世界中存续了下来。我想你可以
could say that Auspolitik, there was a post-Cold War version of Auspolitik in the way in which there was a 70s and 80s version of it. And when the German Chancellor is turning around and saying, actually, we need to break our dependency upon Russian energy, that's a seismic moment. On the other hand, every day that's gone on since the invasion of Ukraine, Germany's been buying gas from Russia that's coming down amongst other pipelines, the Nord Stream 1 pipeline. And there's no evidence, I think, that that is going to change anytime soon so i think what we can see with the announcement that schultz made that germany will build two liquid natural gas ports is that we should expect to see a competition between american producers and russia over the german gas market over the next decade or so which it kind of
说，“东方政策”存在一个冷战后的版本，正如它存在70年代和80年代的版本一样。当德国总理转身说“实际上，我们需要打破对俄罗斯能源的依赖”时，这是一个震撼性的时刻。另一方面，自从入侵乌克兰以来，每一天德国都在从俄罗斯购买天然气，这些天然气通过包括北溪1号管道在内的其他管道输送下来。而且我认为没有任何证据表明这种情况会在短期内改变。所以我认为，从舒尔茨宣布德国将建造两个液化天然气港口的声明中我们可以看到，我们应该预料到在未来十年左右的时间里，美国生产商和俄罗斯将在德国天然气市场上展开竞争，这有点
ironically kind of reconstructs that competition between the americans and russians over european markets about oil at the beginning of the the 20th century but i'm not sure we should necessarily bet on the russians losing that um not least because china's extraordinarily high demand now for gas which which went accelerated through 2021, means that there's extremely fierce competition for liquid natural gas. And Helen, do you think, I mean, with China, obviously, that's, we haven't really talked about China, but its explosive economic growth over the past few decades has obviously been a massive additional factor in the geopolitics of oil. Do you think that Russia may end up in an increasingly subordinate role to China, particularly if China comes to Russia's rescue in its current crisis? What impact that might have on oil consumption from Russia and the world more generally? I think that the fact that Putin is overreached does strengthen China's overall
讽刺地重现了20世纪初美国人和俄罗斯人围绕欧洲石油市场的竞争。但我不敢确信俄罗斯一定会输掉这场竞争，不仅仅是因为中国对天然气异常高涨的需求——这种需求在2021年加速增长——意味着对液化天然气的竞争极其惨烈。海伦，你认为——对于中国来说，显然——我们还没有真正讨论过中国，但过去几十年里其爆炸性的经济增长显然是石油地缘政治中一个巨大的附加因素。你认为俄罗斯最终可能会在与中国的关系中陷入越来越从属的角色吗？特别是如果中国在当前的危机中对俄罗斯施以援手的话？这可能会对俄罗斯和更广泛世界的石油消费产生什么影响？我认为普京用力过猛的事实确实增强了中国在与俄罗斯关系中的整体
position in its relationship with Russia. I think, though, that we shouldn't get too quickly to the view that Russia's doomed itself in energy terms and economically by what it's done what however because it has the gas and oil quite rightly morally of course we are by what is um happening because asia matters at least as much if not more in the energy future than europe um and i don't think there's any evidence whatsoever so far that either China or India is going to turn away from Russian energy. And indeed, I think there's evidence even in the last 48 hours or so that India has actually been increasing the amount of oil that it's buying from Russia. In a world in which Russia was economically very dependent upon Europe, which was true of that world that brought the Soviet Union to an end.
地位。不过，我认为我们不应该太快得出结论，认为俄罗斯因为其所作所为已经在能源和经济上自取灭亡。无论如何，因为俄罗斯拥有天然气和石油——当然，从道德上讲，我们对正在发生的事情感到……这是理所应当的——因为在未来的能源格局中，亚洲的重要性至少不亚于欧洲，甚至可能更高；而且我认为到目前为止没有任何证据表明中国或印度会背离俄罗斯的能源。事实上，我认为有证据表明，甚至在过去48小时左右的时间里，印度实际上一直在增加从俄罗斯购买的石油量。在一个俄罗斯在经济上高度依赖欧洲的世界里——苏联解体前的那个世界确实如此——
That world doesn't exist anymore because Asian economic development is of the two big countries, China and India, is at such a level that their demand for energy is as important as anybody else's, certainly of Europe's demand for energy. I think that we will see Russia really trying to entrench its energy relationship with those countries and might be willing to let go some of it, at least some parts of Europe. Whether it really would let go of competing in Germany, I think maybe competing for the market in Germany may be another matter. But if oil and gas really matter geopolitically, then nothing's actually really changed in energy geopolitical terms by what's happened in the last few weeks. I mean,
那个世界已经不复存在了，因为亚洲两大经济大国中国和印度的经济发展达到了这样的水平：他们对能源的需求和任何人的需求一样重要，当然也和欧洲对能源的需求一样重要。我认为我们将看到俄罗斯真正试图巩固其与这些国家的能源关系，并且可能愿意放弃一部分、至少是欧洲的某些部分。它是否真的会放弃在德国市场的竞争，我想或许争夺德国市场的竞争可能是另一回事。但如果石油和天然气在地缘政治上真的很重要，那么过去几周发生的事情在能源地缘政治层面上并没有真正改变任何东西。我的意思是，
is that what Putin has done is militarily pushed Russia too far by the looks of it. But I don't think that you can just read off from that and say, well, he's destroyed the entire basis of Russian geopolitical power. I don't quite see that. So if you see this sort of continuity, I mean, I personally completely agree with you. I think these deep continuities are not deflected by even individual wars or defeating wars. But that runs against something that I think a lot of our listeners will be thinking about, which is the climate crisis and the need to get away from gas and oil because the implication of what you're saying is that gas and oil will still be absolutely central factors in world politics for the rest of our lifetimes which i think they will um but for example you know hugh george has a question given the the current culture and climate change does oil count as immoral now do you think there has been a a cultural shift against the sort of the politics of all the world of oil or do you think reality dictates that we'll still be dependent on it you know for the rest of the time we're on this earth i think that there there obviously is a
普京所做的是在军事上把俄罗斯推得太远了，从外表上看是这样。但我认为你不能直接从中得出结论，说他已经摧毁了俄罗斯地缘政治力量的整个基础。我并不完全这么看。所以如果你看到这种连续性——我的意思是，我个人完全同意你的观点，我认为这些深层的连续性甚至不会被个别战争或战败所转移。但这与我预料许多听众会思考的某些事情相悖，也就是气候危机以及摆脱天然气和石油的需求，因为你的话暗示着，在我们的有生之年，天然气和石油仍将是世界政治中绝对核心的要素（我认为它们确实会是）。但例如，乔治（George）有一个问题：鉴于当前的文化和气候变化，石油现在算是不道德的吗？你认为针对石油政治或石油世界的文化转变已经发生，还是说现实决定了我们余生都将依赖它？我认为这显然存在一个
widespread moral revulsion against what using fossil fuels um, that moral revulsion, I think, can coexist with an ignorance about our material dependency upon these energy sources in the present moment. And it goes back to the fact that, as I said earlier, I don't think lots of people find thinking about that very palatable. They don't want actually to understand just how ethically burdensome the energy sources on which our way of life depends are. I think it's also the case that there are good reasons, leaving the climate crisis aside, why lots of countries would like to get away from using at least as much oil and gas.
对使用化石燃料的普遍道德反感，这种道德反感，我认为，可以与对当前我们对这些能源的物质依赖的无知共存。这可以追溯到我之前所说的事实，我认为很多人觉得思考这个问题并不那么令人愉快。他们实际上并不想去了解我们生活方式所依赖的能源在道德上有多大负担。我认为这也是事实，撇开气候危机不谈，许多国家有很好的理由想要摆脱对至少那么多石油和天然气的依赖。
And that is that the geopolitics around them, as we've been discussing, are pretty destructive and worse than dysfunctional at best. And where the supply of oil is concerned, I think we can see that you know there are significant constraints in its future um supply and that that would lead to higher prices that makes economic growth um more um difficult i think where we're heading is a world in which an energy some form of energy transition will take place but that will mean that actually more and more green energy is used without that meaning that less and less fossil fuel energy is used because our growth will just keep going up yeah that will actually be living in a in a more of a multi-energy
这就是围绕它们的的地缘政治，正如我们一直在讨论的，充其量是非常具有破坏性的，比功能失调还要糟糕。就石油供应而言，我认为我们可以看到，你知道，在其未来的呃供应中存在着重大制约因素，这将导致更高的价格，这使得经济增长呃更加困难，我认为我们正在走向这样一个世界，在这个世界中，某种形式的能源转型将会发生，但这实际上意味着更多更多的绿色能源被使用，但这并不意味着越来越少的化石燃料能源被使用，因为我们的增长只会继续上升，是的，这实际上将生活在一个更加多元能源的世界里。
world and that until unless and until a decisive breakthrough, technological breakthrough on storage for solar and wind takes place that would make it possible to electrify many things that are presently done via oil, that's where we're going to be. And that means that the old geopolitics, what we've been spending our time talking about today, and a new geopolitics around green energy, in particular China's advantageous position in relation to green energy, are going to coexist with each other. So we're going to have an even more geopolitically complicated world because we're going to have the old geopolitics and the new geopolitics happening at the same time. So when you say China's advantageous position with green policy, because it's more technologically advanced, do you mean?
世界，并且除非且直到在太阳能和风能储存方面取得决定性的突破，技术突破，这将使把目前通过石油完成的许多事情电气化成为可能，这就是我们要去的地方。这意味着旧的地缘政治，我们今天一直在花时间讨论的，以及围绕绿色能源的新地缘政治，特别是中国在绿色能源方面的有利地位，将彼此共存。因此，我们将拥有一个在地缘政治上更加复杂的世界，因为我们将同时拥有旧的地缘政治和新的地缘政治。所以当你提到中国在绿色政策方面的有利地位时，因为它的技术更先进，你是这个意思吗？
Well, it's two things, or several things. First of all, is that China dominates various bits of manufacturing that are crucial to green energy, solar panels in particular. It's not a coincidence that one of the first two products that Trump slapped tariffs on China when he began his trade war with China, one was washing machines and the other was solar panels. The second is that at the moment, China just completely dominates both the production and the supply chains around the metals that are necessary for green energy infrastructure and batteries. And in terms of the distribution of rare earth metals in the earth,
嗯，这是两件事，或者几件事。首先，中国主导了对绿色能源至关重要的各种制造环节，尤其是太阳能电池板。特朗普开始对华贸易战时，对中国加征关税的前两个产品之一不是巧合，一个是洗衣机，另一个是太阳能电池板。其次，目前中国完全主导了绿色能源基础设施和电池所需的金属的生产和供应链。就地球上稀土金属的分布而言，
it looks like China's in a pretty privileged position. Now, that doesn't mean that, you know, like mass mining operation, large scale mining operations elsewhere aren't going to find these metals. And it looks like the United States is pretty committed to going down that um route but no one has no country on earth it would seem has for them in terms of known distribution of these necessary metals so they're not likely to be found in they're not likely found in dorset who knows tom or even in wiltshire maybe um well that's that was the question i was going to ask so to be parochial for a second, where is Britain placed in this?
看起来中国处于一个相当特权的地位。现在，这并不意味着，你知道，比如大规模采矿作业，其他地方的大规模采矿作业不会找到这些金属。看起来美国相当致力于沿着这条路线走下去，但地球上没有任何国家，似乎在已知这些必要金属的分布方面为他们所拥有，所以它们不太可能在多塞特郡被找到，谁知道呢，汤姆，甚至可能在威尔特郡，嗯，那是我想问的问题，所以为了稍微狭隘一点，英国在这个问题上处于什么位置？
Because there's obviously lots more in your book that we haven't talked about. You talk about monetary policy, you talk about indebtedness, you talk about currencies, and you also talk about democracy and you talk a bit about Brexit. And I just want, if we look forward in the rest of the 21st century, where does Britain fit into this kind of geopolitics of energy, do you think? Or are we just part of Western Europe? I think that we can see that by the middle of the 2010s that there was a sense in which, and the Cameron government had it and it's continued since,
因为你的书中显然还有很多我们没有谈到的内容。你谈到了货币政策，你谈到了债务，你谈到了货币，你还谈到了民主，你还谈到了脱欧。我只是想，如果我们展望21世纪的其余时间，你认为英国在这种能源地缘政治中处于什么位置？还是我们只是西欧的一部分？我认为我们可以看到，到2010年代中期，有一种感觉，卡梅伦政府有这种感觉，并且自那以后一直延续着，
that Britain has to have a more active position in the Middle East. That in some sense, perhaps symbolically, the East of Suez retreat was over and we're going back to having some attempt to have some capacity to act militarily in the Middle East independently of the Americans. I think that in terms of the issues around Russian energy, we are in a different position than the other big eu countries obviously particularly germany we just were less dependent in part that was a consequence of of north sea oil and gas um which you know is not something that that germany or france um particularly benefited um from and also because once the american shale gas boom started then we embraced liquid natural gas imports in fact we kind of had before i think from the first first liquid natural gas ports have been built earlier than that in britain including taking imports from qatar and that way now Britain isn't the only European country that has a
英国必须在中东采取更积极的立场。在某种程度上，也许具有象征意义的是，苏伊士以东的撤退已经结束，我们将恢复试图具备独立于美国在中东进行军事行动的能力。我认为，在围绕俄罗斯能源的问题上，我们显然与欧盟其他大国处于不同的位置，特别是德国，我们只是依赖程度较低，部分原因是北海油气的结果，你知道，德国或法国并不是特别受益于此，而且一旦美国页岩气繁荣开始，我们就拥抱了液化天然气进口，事实上我们在那之前就已经开始了，英国更早就建造了第一批液化天然气港口，包括从卡塔尔进口，现在英国并不是唯一一个拥有...
significant liquid natural gas capacity for importing Spain does too but it does distinguish as I think from the from at least the German position I think you know the big hope and you can see this in the way in which Boris Johnson talks about this, is wind, offshore wind. I mean, he's quite, Boris Johnson's quite keen on talking about, you know, Britain being the Saudi Arabia of offshore. He loves a big scheme, doesn't he? He loves a big scheme. And so, obviously, where Sun's concerned,
具备重大液化天然气进口能力的欧洲国家，西班牙也有，但我认为这使它至少与德国的立场不同，我认为，你知道，最大的希望，你可以在鲍里斯·约翰逊谈论这一点的方式中看到这一点，那就是风能，海上风能。我的意思是，他非常，鲍里斯·约翰逊非常热衷于谈论，你知道的，英国是海上风电的沙特阿拉伯。他喜欢宏大的计划，不是吗？他喜欢宏大的计划。所以，很明显，就太阳能而言，
we're in a less propitious position, but we do live in one of the windiest places probably in the world. I think that the political question, leaving aside the high energy cost political question that's coming, will be about fracking in the United Kingdom and about whether the present, essentially anti-fracking position that British governments have taken is going to come to an end. Now it should be said that you can have lots of
我们处于一个不太有利的地位，但我们确实生活在可能是世界上风最大的地方之一。我认为政治问题，撇开即将到来的高能源成本政治问题不谈，将是关于英国的水力压裂法，以及英国政府采取的基本上反水力压裂法的立场是否会结束。现在应该说，你可以有许多...
hopes that fracking will yield you know a lot of gas or oil and they turn out not to. I mean there was a point in the 2010s where Polandand was the great hope um for um shale gas and it turned out that you know the the fracturing the rocks in in poland didn't work out the same way as fracturing the rocks you know like in north in north dakota so just the the the possibility um that oil and gas can be extracted that way doesn't mean that actually it will turn out in practice. I mean, you've only got to look at the history of some of the big, huge oil drills that turn out absolutely for there to be nothing there.
希望水力压裂法能带来大量的天然气或石油，结果却并非如此。我的意思是，在2010年代有一段时间，波兰是页岩气的巨大希望，结果证明，你知道，波兰岩石的压裂并不像北达科他州那样行得通，所以仅仅通过这种方式开采石油和天然气的可能性，并不意味着它在实践中一定会变成那样。我的意思是，你只需要看看一些大型石油钻井的历史，结果发现那里绝对什么都没有。
There's a famous one in Alaska, I think it's called Mokluk, where they spent billions on this. And then when they got there, when they found where the oil should have been, it had moved. And they basically said that they were 30 million years too late.
阿拉斯加有一个著名的钻井，我想它叫莫克卢克（Mokluk），他们在上面花了数十亿美元。然后当他们到达那里，找到本该有油的地方时，油已经移位了。他们基本上说他们晚了3000万年。
That's quite late. Okay, that's not good. But do you think, I mean, do you think that the strains that, certainly, you know, the European economy and the global economy more generally, I guess, that suffering at the moment, that it will inhibit the drive to net zero that it will be maybe net zero but not yet
这可真够晚的。好吧，这可不好。但是你认为，我的意思是，你认为目前欧洲经济以及更广泛的全球经济正在遭受的压力，它会抑制实现净零排放的动力吗，它可能是净零但不是现在？
yeah i mean the thing is is that i think there's two different things going on here is is there's a set of issues around the energy transition and particularly the idea that net zero can be done by 2050 which rests on assumptions about technology that doesn't exist yet. And so I think that there will be a pushback against net zero as it becomes clear how difficult using much higher levels of green energy is. And then there's this, what I would call this fossil fuel energy crisis going on that's being driven by its own dynamics and isn't being caused by the attempts at the energy transition, despite the fact that some people, particularly on the right, the kind of like Farage take on it, would want to sort of blame high energy prices pre-Ukraine on the green energy transition. That's not right. I don't think that that's right at all. It's the dynamics of fossil fuel energy themselves, issues around oil and gas supply and demand that are producing the structural forces,
是的，我的意思是，事情是这样的，我认为这里有两件不同的事情在发生，一是围绕能源转型的一系列问题，特别是到2050年可以实现净零排放的想法，这依赖于尚不存在的技术假设。因此，我认为随着人们越来越清楚使用更高水平的绿色能源有多么困难，将会出现对净零排放的抵制。然后是这个，我称之为正在发生的化石燃料能源危机，它由自身的动力驱动，并不是由试图进行能源转型的企图引起的，尽管有些人，特别是右翼人士，比如法拉奇对它的看法，会想要把乌克兰之前的髙能源价格归咎于绿色能源转型。那是不对的。我认为那完全不对。是化石燃料能源本身的动力，围绕石油和天然气供求的问题，正在产生结构性力量，
that are the structural forces that are pushing high energy or creating high energy prices. So my view is that we'll be dealing with these problems simultaneously and we'll be trying to find ways of living with high fossil fuel energy prices and at the same time trying to find ways of increasing green energy. And those problems will interact with each other in pretty politically complicated ways. Fun times. Helen, thanks so much. Not just the history of oil, but appear into the future as well.
这些结构性力量正在推动高能源价格或创造高能源价格。所以我的观点是，我们将同时处理这些问题，我们将试图找到适应高化石燃料能源价格的方法，同时试图找到增加绿色能源的方法。这些问题将以非常政治上复杂的方式相互作用。美好的时光。海伦，非常感谢。不仅是石油的历史，也是对未来的展望。
And no one better qualified to give it than you and your book, Disorder, Hard Times in the 21st Century. Slightly depressing title that's more than justified itself since its publication is out now. Thanks so much. It's a pleasure, Tom.
没有人比你和你的书《无序：21世纪的艰难时期》（Disorder, Hard Times in the 21st Century）更有资格给出这个了。这个略显沮丧的书名自出版以来已经得到了充分的证明，现在已经上市。非常感谢。这是我的荣幸，汤姆。
Dominic, thank you. Bye-bye. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
多米尼克，谢谢你。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听额外单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。